because you are required to prove this
right you can't use this as a starting
point and then take Tanner both sides
right because then you've assumed what
you're required to prove right so you
absolutely cannot take care of both
sides of this line you will take Tanner
both sides eventually ok but that can't
be your starting point so the easiest
way was to say look these guys here
right work with these two i can simplify
them and then get over to this side
rather than the other way i can think of
them as angles i can situate them as
angles in a triangle ok so you would say
you know not equal to X let that equal
to Y and then you can draw a pair of
trails right here you'd say well 10x is
going to be do that right so then you
draw a triangle it's Samuel ok it's the
x over here opposite on adjacent to
Three that makes this the square root of
13 ok so there's one of the arm angles
I'm gonna need and then over here I can
say what looks like not tank cause y is
equal to 20 root 5 what so you've got
triangle you stick y over here so
adjacent and hypotenuse which gives you
one over there yes ok so now you can
consider right so this is your starting
point now you can say you can set up ten
or X plus y right so because they're
adel's you can just consider this as the
expansion really really busy so this
will be 10 X 10 y 1 minus okay so this
is my father easiest way to harvest it
up rather than trying to do care a cos
inverse anyway it did work but I think
this is much more straightforward and
much simpler and it's not like it took
you a long time to do it either ok so
once you've read it off all out of here
you ended up with the right fractions
thurs now by the way just as a side note
this is a proof question right show just
like so many of them are there are three
marks divided here so you can't simply
say at this point I know this is going
to be 7 over 4 even though it is right
that's cheating you have to show it okay
so this line here is critical to
actually show that I know where all of
these come from and I read them off
these triangles okay then it does
simplify out tantus right and so now you
can take 10 inverse of both sides and
immersive both sides okay on this side
you just get X plus y which is this and
then on the right-hand side you just
have tan inverse of 7 over 4 which is
what you needed right so can you see
even though the mass like the crunching
ends up much the same your starting
point something like this sets the
solutions apart okay it's it's a part of
people who know what they're doing and
the people who are struggling and think
hmm what can I do with this I know I'll
just listen watch out for that